[Music]
subhan allah brothers and sisters
this shows you that subhanallah when you
have the dean inside you
it doesn't really matter what makhan
what status you reach
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are inshallah
came across this video from i think the
brothers name is called mohammed al-nini
he's a player for arsenal he's a
football player for arsenal
and probably that's for arsenal good
money from a mistake a minimum 150 000
pounds
a week or more now that's very good and
well-broken sisters
the question that needs to be asked is
before we actually react to what happens
uh
this video that we're talking about is
him in his car i'm showing his luxury
car
where he is um listening to the quran
and reciting along subhanallah brothers
and sisters
this shows you that subhanallah when you
have the dean inside you
it doesn't really matter what makhan
what status you reach
you can be a millionaire a billionaire a
poor person
you can be someone that doesn't have
nothing you can be someone that has
mediocre
you can be somebody that can have
whatever it may be of the materialistic
things
but when the quran is in the heart
brothers and sisters
that makes you rich then you can ever be
rich
in the material sense brothers and
sisters it brings you tranquility
tranquility in your heart because when
i'm watching this video of this arsenal
player and i can see him reciting and i
can see
this sincerity and when it comes to
certain verses where his
voice trembling and emphasizing on
certain
words in the quran he leaves you asking
a simple question
what what is this what kind of book is
this
what kind of a religion is this what
kind of a way of
life is this for a lot of people
that are watching this maybe non-muslims
watching this that it penetrates the
heart in such a beautiful way
that no matter what you have in life you
know let go because i know i've noticed
thinking about it's like it's amazing
from little kids reciting the quran
memorizing quran to football players to
millionaires to billionaires
to you know those who are going to mecca
and all dressing up the same even
you don't even know who's rich to poor
this is the religion
that brings these people no barriers but
brings them to the unity of worshiping
one and one god alone
let's watch this video and we're going
to go through these verses quickly i'm
going to give you guys a little reminder
because a lot of people let's watch
first i'm gonna come to the whole lot of
people thing let's watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
m
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a
[Music]
loss for words absolutely
loss for words guys you know for him you
know subhan allah brothers and sisters
how many of you guys
how many off are subhan allah you know
just think about it you know if he was
given opportunity from the wealth and
the
stature the status the stuff that he has
well like some of us would panel that we
would give away our dean
we would we would throw our deen on the
bus just to have a stature
because that's how much we are occupied
in this materialistic world we think
this is all
it yeah and some of us
imagine you ask yourself this question
bomb says there are some people out
there subhanallah
if a proposal came from this brother
football player and he asked the sister
okay i don't know take your hijab off or
do this or do that
whatever it may be we are so yeah
it's like we worship materialism so much
that we would
take hijab of no problem brothers would
do anything to reach it
anything leaving the dean up i'm not
praying salah whatever it may be just to
reach that promises because that's how
much we're obsessed with it
and somebody who has reached that hasn't
forgotten his lord
having hasn't forgotten the words the
kalam of his lord and he recites it
subhan allah beautifully
and in such a way subhanallah that his
voice is trembling his voice is
trembling brother and sisters this shows
you bro and sisters
carry money in your hand not in your
heart allah
until you visit the graves and no
you will surely know and allah says and
no
you are surely going to know brothers
and sisters do not let their worthy life
delude you
deceive you yeah once your iman is
checking you got that connection with
your lord it doesn't matter if you're
rich or poor
because that contentment that that
peace you have in your heart that is
something you cannot get with money
wealth whatever it may be
if you attach your heart to money and
wealth and things that's gonna bring you
happiness is
never gonna bring happiness because
that's a condition allah set in place
once you have the quran in your heart
what can anyone do to you your peace and
tranquility and love
is what it's the quran it's remembers of
allah
in your heart no matter if your
condition changes from good health to
bad health
to wealthy from poor to
life and death whatever it may be once
you have that
there is nothing that can shake you
brothers and sisters
and this is the reason why we need to
fix our affairs with allah and allah
fix our affairs with the people and with
our
life brothers and sisters and somebody
like him
who's rich wealthy doing this
it's a reminder for us brothers and
sisters
enter allah in your heart not literally
of course
get the kalam of allah in your heart
brothers and sisters and then you will
see what peace and tranquility is
and none of these worldly material or
these things would
bother you till next time hope you guys
enjoyed this video bomb sisters
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh
you